[Music]
hey it's May
it's the perfect month to go to space
and fight aliens or something I don't
know but we do have a few indie games
this week - if those are more your speed
anyway don't forget to hit that
subscribe button to stay up to date on
all the hottest games each and every
week t-minus three two one and we're
lifting off with prey it's been more
than ten years since the original but
since this game has nothing to do with
that one you can just jettison those
memories out into space this is the
story of Morgan you exploring an alien
infested space station after experiments
go horribly wrong it's been described as
Bioshock in space which makes sense
given all the Handy weapons and powers
you can pick up although Bioshock never
did let you possess a coffee mug anyway
praise coming to ps4 Xbox one and PC on
Friday May 5th but if you want some
space action right now and you don't
want to wait for the review you can
always check out the games opening our
demo look I don't want to assume
anything here but when I hear a name
like the caligula effect I get a very
specific mental image
oh it's just a JRPG well okay then
the Caligula effect is set in a virtual
reality program kind of like the matrix
but with a neverending idyllic
highschool I guess some people would
actually want that anyway your character
realizes this whole thing is a sham and
the dungeon-crawling
RPG stuff kicks off as you try to escape
the game released in Japan last year but
it's coming to North America and
European Vita's on Tuesday May 2nd april
showers bring May flowers and you
couldn't ask for a better setup for
tumble seed your goal is to climb a
procedurally generated mountain avoiding
holes and beating enemies but here's the
thing you climb that mountain by using
your twin sticks to roll and balance
your way up which is why the devs call
it a rolly roguelike 5 world's more than
30 powers and a bunch of extra
challenges means you'll be spending a
lot of time on those mountains you can
start planting seeds on ps4 PC and
Nintendo switch on May 2nd speaking of
planting seeds super rude bare
resurrection lets you plant your own
corpse making new platforms and meet
shields across the levels I don't want
to call it the dark souls of platformers
but I will just so I can throw in this
sick montage
the thing with super rude bear is that
if you're good enough you don't have to
die at all but hey the more you fail the
easier you'll make things for yourself
maybe the bear isn't so rude after all
you can give it a shot on ps4 Xbox one
and PC on May 5th if you want a less
violent indie game then let me suggest
world to the west
it's an action puzzle game with a band
of four characters exploring an ancient
civilization each has their own unique
abilities like super-strength and
mind-bending and there are plenty of
other friends and enemies along the road
to world to the west is coming to ps4
Xbox one PC and we you know seriously
Wii U on May 5th and those are the big
games we'll be playing this week as
always remember that release dates are
based on retailer listings and are
subject to change thanks for watching
guys and I'll be back with more great
games next week
you